es ist eine falle ja das ist alles
einfach darum darfst du das denn nicht
alle brunnen sind fallen
das ist endlich mal summen wo ist
darüber hab ich sehe ich nicht ich habe
komplett lover von oben scheiße alter
ich bin total scheintot alter junge
deine ganze items sind verbrannt
die kann man sich ja leicht morgen hieß
es relativ günstig eigentlich aber
so echt mal wieder zu dir
ich nehme ich noch mal wichtige sachen
mit
ich komme wieder zu dir wissen überhaupt
karte ich bin weiter dahin laufen wo ich
wünsche dem laufenden irritiert war okay
genau die anderen da war nämlich noch
andere gebäude gesehen zurück zu koppeln
in derart aus gips ton
da würde ich eigentlich schon mal
nachgucken damit hat richtig viel
erfahrung auf dem erfahrungs tischmann
benutzen wenn es ein vulkan da breitet
sich grad lava aus nicht ich hab gehört
ich sollte ich nicht solche leute dafür
bezahlen lassen wo bislang die
koordinaten es auch in der andere
richtung erlitten weil diese kommission
ist okay ich hab allerdings gefunden mit
erbsen allerdings mit erste was man
ersten meetings okay was sollen drin
gold wahrscheinlich mehr gold ich weiß
trotzdem nicht alle da kann ich einfach
runter gehen das weiß ich nicht
hier ist nur gold dazu es ist eine falle
ist eine verletzt ist der fall es ist
eine falle es ist eine falle ja das ist
alles einfallen warum sagst du das denn
nicht alle brunnen sind fallen
rombach ist ein wo wissen darüber hab
ich sehe dich nicht ich habe komplett
lover von oben scheiße alter dann baue
die decke oben zubau den brunnen zu mit
cobblestone dann kommt kein läufer zu
der unter anderem wird sagte wo es viele
pisten dann komme ich
ich weiß nicht ich bin jetzt in die
andere richtung
aber hier ist hier bist du nicht ja das
kommt auf ein duo am haus einfach so
einfach abhauen meister ja weil du
brauchst du so lange du bist du bald
drin wo ich gar nicht sein will so da
hatte ich hatte diamant gefunden ickx
und der drei diamanten kombi hin
ich habe gerade krieg hat ist auch
wichtiger den zu töten das sind z den
nur zwei diamanten schade
hier kommen acht okaka
ich hab den abgebauten scram runter
gestürzt ich hab's überlebt ich habe
überlebt ich habe überlebt ihn
eingeschlossen und diesen als talentiert
nein das recht auf achtung jetzt kommt
meine ich bin tot
herrlich ja ich bin gut ich bin total
scheiße ich bin tot alter junge deine
ganze items sind verbrannt
als anders das zusätzlich noch lava ich
hoffe dass wir nur der kreml als falle
der mich erschlagen hier sollte aber da
ist auch noch zeug runtergekommen ach du
kacke ja alles weg rechts kacke der
solar hell mit die zauberstäbe bis nach
mussas von alles was wir gefunden haben
diamanten heftig das ist fies wenn man
die ganzen fallen nicht kennt ja und wie
komme ich jetzt hier raus das kann ich
nicht sagen
pudel ich an der seite raus oder so
weiter über die ist ja genauso lava
meine glück spitz hat es übrigens weg
wie diamant schön sein wie soll ich denn
so mancher zurückkommen fakten eigentor
gewesen ist jetzt also ich musste mein
zeug zusammen kriegen ich hatte die
falsche hatte ich im wesentlichen aber
nichts allzu speziell toll was glaube
ich also nichts was man nicht wieder neu
machen könnte walter jetzt einfach krass
an regnen ich glaube dass live public
viewing statt
ok also ist glaube ich nichts weg was
nicht wieder mal halt beide sehr gut das
problem ist alt war trotzdem sehr viel
genau ist alles noch drin war
ja man kann das denkmal wieder
hinkriegen also ich musste da man nicht
so viel also schon relativ viele schon
herber verlust muss ich sagen
horst willkommen und direkt ein krieg
bei mir am helllichten tag und der
schießt man mit luca unterwegs sein ist
schlecht ja ohne wird einer der wirklich
rumläuft er stirbt einfach dass bei
denen also dass wir simon so das wetter
prima das war mir so wir haben wir als
er aber die partie war echt komisch hab
nur gedacht wenn du deine 30 jahren
geben meinte nein meine ich nicht da
jetzt ganzes dorf glaube ich nicht mehr
als im zweiten vierteljahr will stop sie
hat jetzt 62 und noch mehr weil ich habe
86 86
ich muss dann erst mal wieder meine
rüstungs zeugnis so aufbauen
wie gesagt das wichtigste man kann alles
wieder neu machen ich hab's ja schon mal
gemacht kann theoretisch alles
wiederherstellen ist dauert jetzt wieder
bis ich mein ganzes zeug wieder zusammen
gekriegt habe erster linie brauche ich
glaube ich erst mal ein eisen hose
wieder die volle machen sonst würde man
halt das ist ein lauf lesen dass die
schließliche belecke schließlich tun
aber die falle war richtig fies das kann
man mir eine aufnahme sehen die war
richtig fies wenn ihr die aussagen die
bei gemeinde war auch gemein
der cray wissenschaft gew schlägt
michael gerber nach unten raus buddeln
müssen hätte ich über das legt man sich
dann im nachhinein ja ich wo ich kannte
ja vorher nicht das war eine neue ich
habe gedacht es wäre einfach hingenommen
aber ich hätte eigentlich schon sein
müssen so dass sowie die diamanten
angeboten wurden dass das waren falle
aber nein ich bin ja zu gutmütig was war
denn da wo andere ärzte oder was war da
hängen an der decke einfach zwei jemand
ernst ich hab ein sub geboren ist
komplett decke runter gefallen die kreml
ich habe nur überlebt weil über mir
gerade noch ding und zwar und diamant
block noch und deshalb wo ich ihn vom
kreml erschlagen also viele der kreml
ist darum die leute zu erschlagen habe
ich den kräftig gebauten anlage von oben
wo das weiß ich nicht ob der fall
das war richtig fies dann ich segert
volkswirtschaft und rupert riess endlich
robert racing a und o so sagen da
braucht man schon ordentlich als ich bin
locker dabei hier
ich habe einen normalen wohnung zwei
sich nicht allzu viel mitgenommen
der einfach holz müssen kräftig fällt
sowieso ein schlauch wasser anordnet
genau das thema batterie setzlinge doch
einfach ab dann holst du dir doch
einfach da noch die bäume wachsen
ich habe mein zeug hier wieder zusammen
ist ja furchtbar ist so gestorben wie
wird bin ich der stadt weg meine kassels
verkleiden sich gerade die so klein
dazu weiß ich nichts
herr wo sich denn hier werde ich von der
stadt weg bin
grün dem du einfach kurz auf den punkt
und dann oder richtung des weg punktlos
aber wo ich kann mal kurz weg bombardier
verschwinden die andauernd bei mir aber
ich habe mein ladies day punkt
vielleicht kann ich ja noch mal hin
finden und was dann noch ein tier ist
und so ein zeug wahrscheinlich
verschwunden seien aber von lava
erschlagen vergessen was ich habe wasser
gesetzt unter mir ich habe wasser
gesetzt ich kann nicht nur mehr springen
aber was ich da bin das dauert wieder
zum installiert ist einfach traurig ist
und als partner gefunden da waren zwei
entscheidende bücher darin nicht gut ja
62 leitern alter so was könnte ich die
kiste was kann ich denn da rein packen
was brauche ich denn ich brauche das was
ich habe ich hab nix und dort dreimal so
drei publikums bei mir drin so jetzt
laufe ich aber den dingsbums allerdings
hatten über den vulkan ist es glaube ich
persönlich natürlich ein apfel
jetzt kann ich ein bisschen sprinten
noch nen apfel
ich bin auf dem rückweg kugler
bezeichnen kann ich bin grad ließen das
ist das gar nicht mit der sie tadellos
der steinchen der stein an stein der aus
wie thaddeus du siehst aus wie dem stil
haug nein wirklich so die kammer jetzt
fragen sich welche meine freude ist
nicht mal in 19 minuten wieder das war
furchtbar
bei mir schon reiter will sollte man
mittendrin ich bin jedenfalls hier ist
ein fest zu schauen wir sind sich herum
im anschluss relog ende der
datenübertragung wenn ich auf dieser
waffe noch mal neu trotz normaler
probieren
obendrauf ja ok passt jetzt startet
wieder am 31 jetzt so hallo an alle zur
nächsten folge vom mega projekt letzte
heute gestorben lukas auch wieder dabei
oder immer noch dabei gerade bisschen
rum gelegt und jetzt will ich aber
werden heute aufgegangen übels
abgestorbenes letzten wird das echt
scheiße dafür ist jetpack neu machen
jetpack aber ich glaube schon tausend
mal gefragt ist nicht so aufwendig zu
machen oder na ja ist schon mal gefragt
ist nicht ganz so abhängig zu machen es
geht relativ schnell bei de france zu
den materialien also körper und das
ganze zeug und batterien und teile
kloster brauchst du dafür auch bloß dann
habe ich auch james hat die zauberstäbe
ich auch verloren hat damit sogar extra
einen weiteren abbau zauberstein
mitgenommen der noch nicht angebrochen
war man der soffin weg bei dir
nein habe ich nicht welche baurecht
wolle dass der koloss auf verschwunden
alter alter ach das ist eine treppe die
hier nach unten geht ich dachte schon
ich wollte einfach mal runter da sind
wir ganz viele andere sportler dann habe
ich mich etwas verbietet ein scheiß ich
hab mich voll gefreut dass ich jetzt
keine monster hier sind es regnet im
alltag ist
so wird man kurz muss man kurz den
kleinen cup machen
er machte klar dass kinder da fand ich
es ganz toll man kann ja nicht mal statt
1000 meter so essen bräuchte ich mal hab
ich nämlich nichts mehr da
doch ich weiß was ich glaube ich mache
mir nur farben und mit zusätzlichen
mitzieht und sowas allem kein kommentar
kommt einfach sowas öko fan sieht
setzlingen jahr habe ich schon habe ich
schon daher stimmt dass doch wieder bei
dir bauen wir uns wieder anfängst das
stimmt tatsächlich sein ich bin online
ich brauchs gerade im moment bräuchte
ich es theoretisch statt 800 meter